NON-POLITICAL.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TIME FOR A BOMBSHELL "HANNITY"
WATCH ON THE DEEP STATE.
THIS TAKES A LOT OF EXPLAINING.
WE WILL MAKE IT UNDERSTANDABLE
AND BREAK IT DOWN FOR YOU.
IT'S THE ABUSE OF POWER AND
CORRUPTION.
WE HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU ALL
ABOUT THIS.
IT IS TONIGHT FAR WORSE THAN WE
HAVE KNOWN UP TO THIS POINT.
WE KNOW TOP PEOPLE WITHIN THE
FBI FILLED WITH HATRED AND
ANTI-TRUMP RAGE PUT ASIDE ALL
VALUES.
SEEKING REDEMPTION FOR THE
FIRING OF JAMES COMEY.
THEY PLOTTED TO DESTROY YOUR
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO THIS REPORT THE
FRIDAY "NEW YORK TIMES"
ANONYMOUS SOURCES, SEVERAL TOP
FBI OFFICIALS QUESTIONED WHETHER
OR NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
WORKING DIRECTLY FOR RUSSIA.
THEY DID THIS WITHOUT A SINGLE
SHRED OF EVIDENCE.
ZERO PROBABLE CAUSE, ZERO PROOF
OF ANY COLLUSION.
IT WAS A WITCH HUNT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN RIGHT
FROM DAY 1.
THEY OPENED AN INVESTIGATION
INTO WHETHER OR NOT RUSSIA
DIRECTED THE PRESIDENT TO FIRE
THEIR BELOVED HATER JAMES COMEY
DESPITE COMEY'S TESTIMONY THERE
WAS NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
FOR 9 MONGST THEY WERE LOOKING
INTO THIS AND TRUMP WAS NOT THE
TARGET OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
EVEN COMEY THE TRUMP HATER
ADMITTED THAT THE PRESIDENT
COULD FIRE HIM FOR ANY REASON.
CONGRESSMAN RATCLIFFE SAID IN
MAY OF 2017 POLITICAL BIAS
INFECTED SENIOR FBI LEADERSHIP
AND EMOTION AND NOT EVIDENCE
DROVE THEIR DECISION MAKING.
HIS CLOSED DOOR INTERVIEW WITH
JAMES BAKER REVEALED THIS:
FBI SENIOR LEADERSHIP COULD NOT
ACCEPT THAT COMEY WAS FIRED FOR
CAUSE AND THE PRESIDENT HAD THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO
TERMINATE COMEY.
THEY WILL BEGAN THE WITCH HUNT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER
ATTORNEY JOHN DAWD CALLED THE
ANTI-TRUMP OPERATIONS A
POLITICAL COUP.
>> LITTLE DID I KNOW THAT IT
APPEARS THAT THEY WERE ALL IN IT
TOGETHER.
I MEAN ROSENSTEIN, COMEY,
MUELLER.
McCABE AND THE WHOLE CROWD.
THEY WERE OUT TO GET THIS
PRESIDENT NO MATTER WHAT.
I DON'T THINK THEY BELIEVED
ANYTHING ABOUT RUSSIA.
THIS IS OUR WORST NIGHTMARE.
THAT SOMEONE WITH THAT KIND OF
POWER WOULD DECIDE TO GO AFTER
THE PRESIDENT.
IT'S A COUP.
IT'S AN ATTEMPTED COUP BY COMEY
AND HIS CROWD.
THE EVIDENCE IS ALL THERE.
I THINK THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
ARTICLE IS AN ADMISSION OF THEIR
BAD BEHAVIOR.
>> Sean: ADMISSION OF CORRUPTION
AND ABUSE OF POWER BY PEOPLE
THAT ARE UNCHECKED.
UNLIMITED POWERS AND NO
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IS THIS GOOD FOR AMERICA?
DO THESE DEEP STATE OFFICIALS DO
ANYTHING OTHER THAN -- THE TOP
OFFICIALS THAT HATE THE
PRESIDENT?
ARE YOU REALLY SURPRISED?
THESE ARE THE SAME BUREAUCRATS
THAT ROOTED FOR HILLARY CLINTON
TO WIN THE ELECTION.
AND PETER STRZOK WHO SAID ALL OF
THOSE HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
THE SAME OFFICIAL WHO WROTE AN
EXONERATION IN MAY OF 2016
BEFORE INTERVIEWING HILLARY
CLINTON AND 16 OTHER WITNESSES
IN JULY BEFORE THEY EXONERATED
THER.
IT WAS WRITTEN BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW
THAT HILLARY CLINTON OBJECTED
JUSTICE.
SHE DESTROYED SUBPOENAED EMAILS.
33,000 OF THEM.
WASHED HER HARD DRIVE WITH
BLEACH AND SMASHED iPHONES WITH
A HAMMER AND TOOK AWAY SIMCARDS.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO LOOKED THE
OTHER WAY WHEN HILLARY CLINTON
AND THE DNC FUNNELED MONEY
THROUGH A LAW FIRM TO FIRE A
RESEARCH FIRM TO HIRE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE A FOREIGN
NATIONAL TO GIVE US RUSSIAN
LIES.
THE SAME BUREAUCRATS THAT
APPLAUDED WHEN CLINTON'S FUNNEL
CASHEWSED  -- CASH WAS USED TO
PRODUCE A DOSSIER ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HELPED
DESIMINATE THOSE RUSSIAN LIES
THAT SHE PAID FOR, DOING THAT
BEFORE AN ELECTION.
TRUSTED OFFICIALS WHO USED THE
DOSSIER TO DEFRAUD A FISA COURT
TO SPY ON A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE.
FRAUD BEFORE THE COURT.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO USED THAT
DOSSIER TO OPEN UP AN
INVESTIGATION INTO TRUMP.
THIS ALL HAS HAPPENED AND YEAH,
A BASELESS INVESTIGATION INTO A
PRESIDENT BEING CONTROL BY
RUSSIA IS NOW JUST PAR FOR THE
COURSE.
THE HYSTERIA OF THE MEDIA IS
WORSE.
THIS WAS 9 MONTHS AFTER THEY
WERE ALREADY INVESTIGATING
COLLUSION AND LISA PAGE AND
JAMES COMEY AND ANDREW McCABE
HATE TRUMP AND SAID THEY HAD
NOTHING.
MARK PENN POINTS OUT THE BLATANT
UNEQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
"EVERY CLEAR SECURITY BREACH IN
THE CLINTON CAMP WAS NO BIG DEAL
AND EVERY 4th HAND CONTACT WAS
EVIDENCE THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
SECRETLY SERVING THE RUSSIAN
AGENT.
>> ARE WE CRIMINALIZING OR
EXERCISING THE AUTHORITIES OF
THE FBI TO INVESTIGATE POLICY
DIFFERENCES?
TO INVESTIGATE FOREIGN POLICY BY
AN ADMINISTRATION?
THAT'S NOT THE ROLE OF THE FBI.
>> Sean: NO IT'S NOT AND THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION
ROLLS ON.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING INTO
HILLARY CLINTON OR PHONEY
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
THEIR FOCUS IS ON PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
AND EVERYONE AROUND HIM.
TONIGHT ONE SO-CALLED JOURNALIST
FROM THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA IS
TRYING TO PLAY DOWN EXPECTATIONS
ABOUT TRUMP AND RUSSIA AND ABOUT
THE MUELLER REPORT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT I AM GETTING IS THAT
THIS IS ALL BUILDING UP TO THE
MUELLER REPORT AND RAISING
EXPECTATIONS OF A BOMBSHELL
REPORT.
EXPECTATIONS HAVE BEEN BUILDING
FOR OVER A YEAR ON THIS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE CLOSEST TO WHAT
MUELLER HAS BEEN DOING
INTERACTING WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, THIS REPORT IS ALMOST
CERTAIN TO BE ANTI-CLIMATIC.
>> Sean: I DON'T TRUST WHEN YOU
JUST HEARD.
GIVING THE PARTISAN MAKEUP OF
MUELLER'S TEAM AND THEIR
BEHAVIOR THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
WITH HIGH POWERED DEMOCRATIC
DONORS, THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
DESTROY THE PRESIDENCY OF DONALD
TRUMP.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING IT FOR 2
YEARS AND DID IT BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WHICH SHOULD
CONCERN EVERY AMERICA:
IF THESE DEEP STATE ACTORS
SUCCEED.
FOR GET ABOUT A FREE AND EQUAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, DEAD IN AMERICA.
TAKE THE CONSTITUTION AS WE KNOW
IT AND SHRED IT, BECAUSE THAT'S
OVER FOREVER.
NEVER FORGET THE HATE TRUMP
DEMOCRATS AND HATE TRUMP MEDIA,
THEY HAVE BEEN TIED AT THE HIP
THE WHOLE TIME REPORTING LIES
DAILY.
LAST WEEK, WE SAW THE TALKING
POINT OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
SPIT OUT BY THEIR FRIENDS IN THE
MEDIA.
A MANUFACTURED CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
NO, PEOPLE GETTING KILLED AND
DRUGS CROSSING OUR BORDER,
THAT'S REAL.
WE CONTINUE OUR "HANNITY" WATCH
TONIGHT ON THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN AND THE CRISIS AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THAT THE MEDIA
REFUSES TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
WITH BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS DEAD
LOCKED AND AFTER 10 DAYS ON THE
JOB, MANY CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS TREATED THEMSELVES
AFTER 10 DAYS TO SOME WELL
DESERVED REST AND RELAXATION AT
AN OCEANFRONT LUXURY RESORT.
AND 29 DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS
BOARDED A PRIVATE JET AND WENT
TO PUERTO RICO TO SOAK UP THE
SUN -- OH, THAT'S SUCH A NICE
PICTURE.
THEY ARE WORKING HARD FOR WE THE
PEOPLE AND ATTENDED A SPECIAL
VIEWING OF A BROADWAY HIT PLAY
HANGING OUT WITH OVER 100
LOBBYISTS AND CORPORATE
EXECUTIVES.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO ON THE 10th
DAY OF THE JOB.
GOOD JOB.
WHO PAID FOR THE PLANE AND THE
TICKETS?
JUST A QUESTION.
WE DON'T HAVE ANSWERS YET.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVING FUN IN THE
SUN -- CAN YOU IMAGINE 10 DAYS
AND THEN YOU GO ON VACATION?
I WANT THAT JOB.
I WILL RUN FOR OFFICE.
WE HAVE A CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER IS.
IT'S GOTTEN WORSE.
WHILE THEY ARE ON VACATION, A
NEW MIGRANT CARAVAN IS FORMING
IN HONDURAS SCHEDULE TO DEPART
TOMORROW MORNING AND PLANING TO
CROSS OUR BORDERS AT AN UNKNOWN
TIME AND LOCATION.
WE ARE LEARNING ABOUT A
DANGEROUS FEDERAL LOOP HOLE
LEAVING ALL AMERICANS VULNERABLE
TO VIOLENT GANGS.
LAST WEEK 2 HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
STABBED BY 33 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
WITH MS-13 TIES AND 2 RELEASED
BECAUSE THEY WERE UNACCOMPANIED
ON MINORS ENTERING THE US.
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE.
LAST FRIDAY YOU MET MOTHERS AND
FATHERS ON THIS SHOW THAT LOST
THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE PRESIDENT IS WORKING CLOSE
ON THIS.
TO CLOSE THE AMERICAN BORDER AND
DEMOCRATS ARE ON VACATION.
MAYBE THE PRESIDENT SHOULD OFFER
THEM A TROPICAL VACATION IF THEY
GET THE JOB DONE.
IT'S CLEAR:
WE HAVE A FAR LEFT TAKE OVER OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT BRINGS US TO OUR "HANNITY"
WATCH ON SOCIALISM.
THE DEMOCRATS NEW STAR NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, SHE'S BEEN ON A
MEDIA TEAR.
MOVING HER PARTY FURTHER AND
FURTHER TO THE LEFT WITH CALLS
FOR A 70% TAX RATE.
SHE WANTS TO ABOLISH "ICE."
ALSO GOVERNMENT MANDATED CLIMATE
SHAMING POLICIES.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE COMING
FOR EVERY LAST PENNY.
THESE ARE THE SAME SOCIALIST
IDEAS GAINING MOMENTUM.
LOOK AT NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA.
NEW YORK CITY, THE MAYOR EYEING
A NEW FAR LEFT SCHEME TO
REDISTRIBUTE WEALTH SAYING THIS
IN HIS STATE OF THE CITY ADDRESS
IN NEW YORK.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN THIS
CITY, TENS OF MILLIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE BOXED INTO LIVES
THAT JUST ARE NOT WORKING FOR
THEM.
YOU HAVE NOT BEEN PAID WHAT YOU
DESERVE FOR ALL OF THE HARD
WORK.
YOU HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN THE TIME
YOU DESERVE.
YOU ARE NOT LIVING THE LIFE YOU
DESERVE.
AND HERE, IS THE COLD, HARD
TRUTH:
IT'S NO ACCIDENT.
IT'S AN AGENDA.
AN AGENDA THAT HAS DOMINATED OUR
POLITICS FROM REAGAN-NOMMICS TO
THE TRUMP TAX GIVE WAY TO
WEALTHY CORPORATIONS.
BROTHERS AND SISTERS, THERE IS
PLENTY OF MONEY IN THE WORLD.
THERE IS PLENTY OF MONEY IN THIS
CITY.
IT'S JUST IN THE WRONG HANDS!
>> Sean: HE WANTS TO CONFISCATE
MONTHEY IS IN THE WRONG HANDS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT COMP PASSION.
-- COMPASSION.
THIS IS ABOUT CONTROLLING HARD
WORKING AMERICANS, IN THIS CASE
NEW YORKERS.
SEEING THE SAME THING IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE LEFTIST GOVERNOR WILL TAX
DRINKING WATERS TO ENSURE THAT
THE WATER THEY DRINK IS CLEAN.
THIS IS A STATE WITH A 13.5%
STATE INCOME TAX.
THIS IS A PARTY DEVOID OF
MODERATES AND THEIR SOLUTION TO
EVERY PROBLEM IS TAKE MORE OF
YOUR HARD EARNED MONEY AND
PRETENDS ITS FOR YOUR BENEFIT.